I want to quickly point out you were  just a small part of the studio C cast  contingent we have a bunch of them  sitting in the audience tonight and  there they are you know let me start  first of all that sketch is so funny and  my kids have shown it to me maybe 500  times but it doesn't stop being funny  how many shots were digitally enhanced I  mean how did you do that where you just  kept getting hit in the face yeah all  the wide shots are digital right but the  close-ups  that's all this right yeah we that was  the best part the cast loved it because  they took turns throwing the soccer ball  at my face and that really hurt well  it's a softer ball than you would expect  right but but still yeah it's really fun  we had we were pretty much for close-up  shots we're like 6 feet away from if not  closer just like launching this ball at  his face and he took it well I did yeah  when they connected sounds like you had  no choice yeah well that's true  you